gillian i'm coming to you first as
someone who doesn't love
watching horror movies i've done quite a
few and i'll never stop talking about
bad milo in particular but
someone without the draw to actually
watch them what do you need to see in a
horror screenplay to convince you this
is a space i want to be living in for an
extended period of time
um i think it has to feel slightly
different
from what i've done in the past so this
is very different from bad milo
i think it's very different from them it
is a unique film
um a character that feels like a
challenge or distinct in some way i'm
gonna have to explain bad milo to them
um and also something that's just feels
yeah different um in terms of the
character and difference slightly in
terms of the genre that's what i'm
looking for
i i think it's a successful thing then
here
daryl you are literally like the only
one in the press notes who didn't list
their favorite horror movies so so what
are they
i just don't see that many horror films
but for me i know
jaws um ruined my life because i love
the water
and i love the ocean and now every time
i go in the ocean i'm like
i know jaws is waiting for me somewhere
um and the blair witch project
which i'm still not convinced this day
isn't it's a documentary right
this pair it's got to be adapted okay
cool so
that milo is also a documentary can we
talk about what is that
like that milo is my is my fa is my
favorite horror film
it's a monster that comes out of my
husband's butt
and uh kills people that are uh messing
with him
yeah yeah oh my god
what yeah it's wonderful i swear you
should all see it
yeah that's officially my that that's my
number one horror film bad milo just
read that description alone
a whole lot of sense so while i was
preparing for this it just blows my mind
how many incredible directors you've
worked with like time and time again
so do you notice a shared trait among
the directing greats and then what is
something about lee that makes her stand
out from the pack it's an
incredible i have been so blessed to
work with the directors i have but the
the the shared trait is that
they create a community you they they
really are
about everybody having a voice you know
they're they're they're not directors
who who shy away from like
you know actors well maybe this work
it's very much
it feels like you're a part of a team um
and they're so incredible um i mean
they're just to me i don't i don't know
how i got so lucky
um but i like every one of them that
you're speaking of is
truly like a big part of my life now
and lea is no exception to that because
she's just phenomenal i think that she's
um
i would tell any actor who's watching
this like if you get the opportunity to
work with her like
like run towards it i mean she in the
fact that she directed
three films back to back to back and
wrote them back i mean
i i i'm sounding like a broken record
but like we got to give her something
it's like a lifetime achievement award
that they have or like
i whatever it is like she she deserves
it because she's
and to be so cool while doing that you
know
she there's no ego with her um
she's she's a star she's just a
superstar so i think that
all of them all the ones they're
speaking about they all just they're
just great people
and that's why their stuff is so good
felt that about lee since honeymoon and
it's held true ever since